we've heard a lot about this year about
special prosecutors independent counsels
and congressional investigations but we
don't hear so much about inspectors
general who play a huge and critical
important role in the oversight of your
government there are 72 inspectors
general and they have an enormous staff
of about 13,500 employees joining me now
to discuss his role in duties is Michael
missile from the Department of Veterans
Affairs where he is the inspector
general director inspector general I
want to thank you first of all the
community as a whole I you know we
people I think do think all we need a
special prosecutor particularly when it
relates to the FBI and the Department of
Justice but behind the scenes we already
have embedded into the system people are
essentially their auditors right
what can they look at what can they not
look at and what do we expect the 850
people you employ at the Veterans
Administration to do on a daily basis so
what our job is is do oversight of the
programs and operations of the agency we
do that by conducting audits inspections
reviews and criminal investigations and
what we're really looking for is fraud
waste abuse and inefficiencies so we use
our powers to get whatever information
we want from the agency to talk to
whatever person that they have to
respond to you don't come in with the
Inspector General badge and say I'm here
to talk to you
I need those documents do they have to
give them to you they have to give them
to us absolutely and they do the only
thing that they can't do though is once
they leave and they depart then you
you're you don't have the ability to
reach out and go touch the get that
information we can still subpoena them
for information documents but correct we
do not have the ability to subpoena a
former employee to talk to us so just to
give you hom a sense at the VA you go to
the website by the way if you go to at
oversight gov there's the Twitter handle
it's brand-new with all these
investigations all these reports about
what's going on in your government
oversight gov is also a website that the
viewers at home can go to but just at
the VA you issued 181 reports eleven
hundred and forty-four recommendations
and had a 4.2 billion dollar impact
what you're looking at the VA I mean we
all care about veterans that have served
this nation it seems like a disaster and
a mess where is the VA at today and what
are your biggest concerns we're working
very hard to fix whatever issues we find
we have a hotline that gets 40,000
contacts a year although we triage every
one of those contacts we hear from
veterans we hear from VA employees we
heard from whistleblowers were really
critical to but what's not working well
at the VA today I mean there has been
bills that have been passed in this
Congress President Trump has made it a
priority but today as the Inspector
General looking under the hood what is
your biggest concern at the VA we're
just making sure that the programs
workers are designed and that the money
is spent as appropriated so we've looked
as you pointed out we made a number of
recommendations and hopefully that means
those programs are going to be improved
and then we're always finding other
things we look very hard we have a very
proud staff that works every day to help
make the programs and operations better
for veterans waste fraud and abuse we
all talk about every year people talk
about wanting to root out the waste
fraud and abuse have you've been able to
pin a number on that how big is the
waste fraud abuse it's extremely large
like is that hundreds of dollars is it
tens of billions of dollars and the
billions of dollars just in the last six
months our economic impact was over ten
billion dollars and that's in cost
savings that's in recoveries we had and
other ways we measure economic impact so
what's the number one thing you want
people to know about inspectors general
because particularly over at the
Department of Justice a lot of calls for
a special prosecutor but do you really
need a special prosecutor if you have an
Inspector General like Michael Horowitz
doing their job over there I think one
of the differentiating features about an
Inspector General is our independence we
don't report to anybody we don't report
to the head of the agency we don't
report to Congress so this allows us to
do our job the way we think the best way
possible
it allows us to call it like we see it
to do our job in a fair and objective
manner and to get things right well look
I can tell you as the former chairman of
the Oversight Committee I relied on the
inspectors general across the government
they these people will go dive in for
a year or two and our worry is that they
find this good information and that it
doesn't actually get implemented by an
administration or that Congress forgets
about it when legislations happening so
to the 13,500 inspectors generals the
staff and the 850 people that work for
you at the Veterans Administration
Godspeed we appreciate all that you do
and and looking after our taxpayer
dollars thank you and working hard every
day thank you